freunde was geht herzlich willkommen zu
diesem video ich habe mir seit einiger
zeit eine frage gestellt und zwar wie
schmecken geschmacksverstärker was sind
geschmacksverstärker macht das ganze
sinn ist das gefährlich und ich habe ein
bisschen nachgelesen und herausgefunden
nein die sind überhaupt nicht gefährlich
also geschmacksverstärker sind
glutaminsäure das ist eine von 20
aminosäuren die auch in zahllosen
natürlichen lebensmitteln vorkommt also
pilze tomaten fleisch sozusagen etwas
natürliches und das was wir als
geschmacksverstärker kennen ist häufig
isolierte glutaminsäure und genau das
habe ich hier in diesem weg informiert
das hab ich glaube ich fünf euro
gekostet oder so ich wollte einfach mal
ein bisschen damit herum experimentieren
und deshalb bin ich heute eben gewohnt
habe auch dave an meiner seite mit dem
welche aber gleich ein paar leckere
sachen bestellen und ich probiere das
ganze wissen wo geschmacksverstärker
dabei sind und dave probiert blind wird
also auf jeden fall sehr interessant
probiert das ganze jetzt erstmal in
reinform
ich muss schon sagen ich verstehe
irgendwie so ein bisschen warum leute
davor schiss haben als ist so ein
bisschen ungewohnt hat einfach was viele
auch nicht wissen zum beispiel martin
uns so sind auf geschmacksverstärker
drin also in vielen gewürzmischung aber
ich probiere das jetzt mal in reinform
hier steht zum beispiel darauf freiheit
höher als 99 prozent
glutamat geschmacksverstärker das ist
auf jeden fall so eine geschmacks
komponente die ein relativ schnell an
asiatisches essen erinnert das liegt
daran dass glutamat auch viel in der
asiatischen küche verwendet
ja was ist von dieser undefinierbare
vollmundige geschmack das heißt auch der
essence of money und umami ist ja dieser
fünfte geschmacks sind deshalb sehr sehr
interessant ich würde sagen denkt kommt
gerne mal zu mir ins bett und wir gucken
uns an was wir verstärken möchte erstmal
probier bitte sehr gespannt aber
handlicher auch bisschen gefährdet sieht
höchste so weit so unterschiedliche
kristalle sind sondern aber es schmeckt
texte was ich habe gesagt asiatische
küche also einfach so ein bisschen an
diesem hintergrund mal was schmeckt gut
auf den ohne gar nicht so stark wie ich
gedacht hätte als jahrmarkt fast genau
wenn man würde denken das ist super
kreshnik aber ich hab zum beispiel auch
gehört dass das sogar süße sachen süßer
machten einfach alles intensiver
schmecken lassen müssen jetzt erst mal
die ein oder andere leckerei bestellen
immer ein vorteil mit ihr zu drehen wir
müssen eigentlich die klassiker fest
überhaupt pizza burger sowas burger king
ist bestimmt sowieso
geschmacksverstärker ich habe gerade
gedacht dass er eigentlich witzig aber
das ist das bestätigt schon zu 50 mann
denke zumindest asiatisches essen ist
halt safe sowieso selbst welche dabei
favorit aber es muss so was für eine
gute side by side und per ersten seiten
deshalb würde ich sagen aller papa wir
geben uns jetzt erstmal eine schöne
pizza margherita oder da kann man es am
besten würde ich auch sagen so erste
bestellung ist raus es ist einfach im
dienste der wissenschaft dass ich mir
hier einst das essen sein können
wir brauchen noch einen burger wies
bürger wann ist eigentlich top oder wie
man schnell bringer mw wenn man sehr
viel bestellt und der mindestbestellwert
plötzlich schon zum nba muss dazu wir
warten jetzt ab dass die sachen ankommen
und dann geht es bei ihren den blindtest
für mich ins experiment und wir sehen
uns gleich das erste essen ist schon da
und ich treffe gerade hier die
vorkehrung also ich halte alles und
mache eine hälfte mit und eine ohne gut
er hat also ohne geschmacksverstärker
ich nehme das schon ordentlich also ihr
könnt ja gerade sehen ich bin sehr
gespannt ob dave vor allem unterschied
schmecken würde weil er wird das ganze
ja blind machen
ich glaube mutter markt dadurch dass es
so herzhaft schmeckt eine ganz gute
möglichkeit vielleicht für leute die
müssen auch salz verzichten wollen
schmeckt schon salzig auch also klar
schmeckt so fleischig irgendwie aber
schmeckt auch salzig und deshalb auf
jeden fall schon interessant dieses
bürger stück hier ist mit
geschmacksverstärkern und dieses hier
ohne ich probiere mal ob ich überhaupt
ein unterschied schmecke hier dominiert
auf jeden fall geschafft im geschmack
weniger so der fleischgeschmack wirklich
sehr sehr gespannt ob ich jetzt merke
also ich würde safe sagen ich würde
sagen dass das deutlich eingeschränkt
und dort nicht mehr so dieses volle hat
doch was also wirklich nicht so ein
bisschen sondern für mich das super
eindeutigen kraft ich bin gespannt ob
das für ein bisschen in meinem kopf ist
ein bisschen placebo ist weil ich weiß
was was ist dave weiß das ganze aber zum
glück nicht so habe ich sagen es wird
zeit für den großen test fragen sprechen
auch sehr sehr gespannt für mich warst
super eindeutig ja aber ich wusste wie
gesagt was machst du darfst dir
aussuchen womit du anfängst thomas
burger und sagen ich starte mit
bis jetzt war ich glaube es am
schwierigsten ihre daten mit burger
länder euch dann einläutet was hier ist
offensichtlicher weise sehe ich nichts
gab kein sehr gespannt alter hast du
auch so ein bisschen das gefühl was
falsches zu machen
dafür sollen weiterhin zu finden
natürlich bedenkenlos also ich hab das
kitschig schmeckt komplett normal und
sicher sagen china hat uns nach gucken
ja ist nicht markiert ist also richtig
dass das mag das ja was würdest du
besser aber es bringt es zu schmecken
schmeckt besser wir haben mit gesprächs
nicht das gegessen ist also nicht
griffbereit haben und für euch heute
wirklich es gibt also dave könnte es
nicht erahnen das ist wirklich rein
nicht nennen ich finde irgendwie wenn
wir jetzt den anderen dagegen probier's
der schmeckt frisch weil da wird dieses
herzhafte so krass in den vordergrund
geprügelt aber wirklich an das ist dann
hast du das gefühl bord crazy
ich glaube man kann es den zuschauern
dadurch beschreiben wänden sachen wenn
man sachen gesalzen ist und dann salz
dann ist es auch so eine
geschmacksexplosion erstellen und so ist
hier auch nur dass die sachen ansicht
ist man ja dann richtig sind so dass man
es noch mal verstärken kann ich bin sehr
gespannt
wir machen das ganze in der nächsten
runde mit pizza auch hier erkennt tue
ich nicht
dem hatte ich glück und habe erstmals
ohne geschmacksverstärker gegessen und
dann hatte ich einen guten vergleich
jetzt erstmal weiß das nicht so
genannten okay ich hätte mir richtig
vielleicht habe ich weniger engagiert
sind dann gewartet wir gucken da runter
wenn nichts da ist markiert
das heißt dass das ist nie ohne glutamat
aber dass hier irgendwas war da gerade
richtig
vielleicht haben die da das glutamat
hersteller für solche witze aufgehalten
ja geil also schlecht aber draußen okay
ich habe jetzt auch noch mal ein stück
mit und eines ohne glutamat genommen und
ich probiere das ganze jetzt auch mal
es hat auf jeden fall nicht diesen
effekt wie von bürgern genau also auf
dem burger war das ganz ganz krank bin
mir trotzdem ein dass das ist ja dieses
mal worden hat aber vielleicht ja auch
nie das stimmt also für mich es wird
bestimmt auch so einen großen teil
platziert sein aber es für mich schmeckt
viel mehr hinten also am gaumen einfach
so viel krasser viel präsenter
ok ich wo ich weiß finde das ist klasse
aber es ist deutlich deutlich schwerer
als beim burger 100 prozent wenn die
pizza schon so viel schwieriger war als
der bürger dann ist das die absolute
königsdisziplin dass die leute die
selbst gerne kochen wissen dass man
pommes direkt nachdem sie frittiert oder
aus dem ofen kommt direkt würzen muss
weil sonst die gewürze gar nicht
anhaften projekt es wirklich wert
ich habe auf jeden fall ein bisschen
mehr genommen deshalb und bleibt
spannend
jetzt bist du mit soßen oder ohne
sogleich bekennen das gewürz ist für
mich schon kann halt sehr sehr gut sein
dass das ihr hat schon sehr starken
geschmack ist definitiv dass du kannst
du direkt ein konnten was ist
besser das leider es schmeckt nach ich
weiß nicht ob das irgendjemand fühlt
aber nach freibad pommes ja so viel zu
viel zugelassen sind die polisario
benutzen muss damit du das in
irgendeiner weise überhaupt aushalten
ganz verstehe so schmeckt das guck mal
da runter wenn da nichts markiert ist in
weiß dann sind es die mieten kann man
jetzt noch falsch da findet die hey mann
wurde komplett rausgenommen
ich frage mich auch gerade vielleicht
sind sind hier einfach sein aber man
sieht echt nicht mehr so gut ist auch
wirklich einfach nicht angehaftet oder
sogar leer die haben mir echten alles
lecker lecker wie ich mir zweimal
komplett sicher war und zweimal vertagt
habe man schmeckt ist wirklich sehr
stark deswegen wundert es mich zwei mal
vertan habe beim ersten fall völlig
diffus und wasserkraft ich merke jetzt
gerade auch eigentlich keinen
unterschied aber du hast ihn
unterschiedlich sagt ja ich gehe auf
jeden fall sagte er könne die pommes da
sieht man schon da ist ein bisschen was
dran
naja dann war es einfach toll dass mir
ein bisschen mehr seit erwirtschaft war
auf jeden fall eine kraft erfahrungen
ein bisschen dazu hat mich auch
gugelfuss inspiriert das ist so ein food
youtuber der super viel grillt und er
macht das ganze mit vakuum also er macht
zu 500 euro steckt mit und ohne msg also
ohne geschmacksverstärker und jeder der
bei ihrem test und sagt immer mit
geschmacksverstärker als krasser und das
finde ich so heftig weil sie sich das
beste vom besten ich habe natürlich
jetzt wenig ahnung von dosierung oder so
auf jeden fall trotzdem sehr interessant
wenn ihr das ganze mal sehen wollt mit
süßspeisen getränken oder so dann
schreibt auf jeden fall die kommentare
und zeigt dass mit einem like macht's
gut